تميزت ليندا ريزنك بقدراتها التسويقيه ثم
انتقلت من مروجه ناجحه في التسويق الى
مليارديره تتربع على ثروه تقدر بثمانيه
مليارات دولار صنعتها بكفاءه خلال مسيره
مهنيه امتدت لنحو 50 عاما فما سر هذه
الثروه ولدت ليندا
1944 في ولايه مريلاند الامريكيه وترعرعت
في بنسلفانيا حيث كان والدها جاك اتش هريس
يعمل موزعا للافلام وهو ما ساعدها للظهور
وهي طفله في حلقات من برنامج ذا هورن
انهاردر تشيلد بعد انهائها مرحله الثانويه
انتقلت عائله ليندا الى جنوب كاليفورنيا
والتحقت هناك بكليه محليه لكنها لم تكمل
دراستها بسبب تولي وظيفه بوكاله للاعلانات
حيث اكتسبت بعض الخبره لتؤسس وكاله
اعلانات خاصه بها تحت اسم ليندا في
الطويله مرت ليندا بالعديد من محطات
التوقف والنجاح على الصعيد الشخصي حيث
انتهى زواجها الاول بالطلاق بعد انجابها
طفلين قبل ان تتزوج ستيوارت الذي عاشت معه
محطات متقلبه من النجاح والتعثر قبل ان
تستقر اعمال امبراطوريتهما التجاريه ويجمع
ثروه تقدر بثمانيه مليارات دولار
[موسيقى]